CLAY BAVOR: Good
morning, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Great to see you.
Thanks for being here.
I like the people in
the second section
getting an update on VR
and AR and a good suntan
at the same time.
That's cool.
Good job.
So hopefully, you caught
the news yesterday
in the main keynote.
Great momentum with
apps on Daydream,
more Daydream-ready
phones on the way,
standalone VR headsets with
inside-out positional tracking.
A super precise indoor
location service
we call VPS, and then
an update to Expeditions
that we're really excited about.
So I'm going to be brief here.
And in a minute, we'll
turn it over to the people
on our team who are
actually leading
many of the projects you're
going to hear about today.
But before I do
that, I wanted to put
what we're doing in VR and AR
at Google in context, put some
of the puzzle pieces together
for you so that you can better
understand why we're
doing what we're doing,
and as developers, what
you can expect from us.
So if you've followed
what we've been
up to over the
past several years,
you've seen a bunch
of different pieces--
Cardboard, Daydream,
Tango, Jump, VR apps,
like Earth and Tilt Brush.
We're working in VR.
We're doing some work in AR.
What's going on here?
How do you think about this?
So first of all, terminology.
Over the past year,
especially, I've
seen so many debates about
VR versus AR, which is going
to win, what vocab to use.
And to us, these terms
don't represent two
separate and distinct things.
They're just labels for
different points on a spectrum.
And for lack of
a better name, we
call that the Spectrum
of Immersive Computing.
Fully immersive is at the right.
That's where everything
is computer generated.
That's virtual reality.
And real reality, like
this, is at the left end
of the spectrum.
And AR, and whatever other
terms you want to use,
are somewhere in the middle.
What's important to us is
not the specific labels,
but it's this whole spectrum.
And we're doing work across it.
But why?
Why invest in this?
Why is it important?
Well, VR, AR, Immersive
Computing-- these technologies
matter because they enable
us to experience computing
more like we experience
the real world.
They enable computing
to work more like we do.
And we think that's a big idea.
We think that's
really important.
Because every time
computers have
started to work more like we
do, good things have happened.
If you think about moving from
punch cards to the command line
to the GUI to touch screens,
with every progression,
we became more able, more
capable with our computers.
And we think VR and AR will
push this even further.
They open up access to
an entirely new kind
of information, a kind of
experiential information,
or information that's anchored
physically to the real world.
And we think this progression
is going to be powerful.
And in time, it's going to
change how we work and play
and live and learn.
And we want to help push
this forward in two ways.
So first, platforms.
Just as Chrome made the
web faster, more secure,
more powerful, and as Android
made mobile computing more
widely available, we hope
that platforms like Daydream
can push forward VR
and other technologies.
And our goal here is
really to raise all boats
by doing a lot of the heavy
lifting in the core system
software, device standards,
reference hardware, and SDKs.
And the second part
is building blocks.
And by these, I mean the
enabling technologies,
like Tango, Web VR, our
Jump VR Video Capture
System, code samples, and more.
And we also think
of the apps we've
built, like Tilt Brush or
Earth VR or Expeditions,
as building blocks
in that they're
early examples of VR apps to
look at and to learn from.
So this morning is about exactly
these two things, platforms
and building blocks.
And with that, I'd
like to turn it over
to Johnny Lee, the founder
of the Tango project,
to talk about one of our most
important building blocks.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: Hi, everyone.
It's great to be here.
My name is Johnny Lee.
I'm the engineering
director of Tango.
In 2013, a small group of us
got together with a belief
that one day, our devices would
be able to sense 3D motion
and space just like we can.
And so with the
right combination
of hardware and software,
Tango can give our devices
this 3D sense of
motion-sensing capabilities,
as well as the
ability to recognize
places it's been before.
And so this establishes
a shared sense
of space and physical movement
between people and our devices.
And it allowed us to
begin creating experiences
that gave us an early
glimpse into how
we could interact with digital
content in a physical way.
Today, four years
later, we're starting
to see new genre products
and both AR and VR that
put 3D tracking and sensing as
a fundamental part of the user
experience.
And so Tango has evolved into
an enabling technology that's
powering everything we're
doing within Daydream.
Yesterday, you heard Clay
talk about our support
for standalone VR headsets.
And by building all the
hardware into the headset
and taking advantage of
years of optimization work
with Qualcomm, mobile
processors, low-cost tracking
sensors, we can
enable a headset that
responds to the
movement of the user's
head, similar to desktop
VR systems we see today,
but without all the
cables and setup.
And we call this
technology WorldSense.
And it's a version of Tango
that we've been working on
specifically for VR.
So let me show you a
little bit about how
it works in a headset.
There's two wide-angle
cameras that
detect the movement of
features in the room.
And these features
might be things
like the corners of a
desk, items on the table,
or texture on the floor.
And it tracks the movement
of these features over time
to get a sense of its
position in the room.
We then tightly couple this
visual motion information
with the motion
sensors on the phone
to provide robust, low-latency
positional tracking.
And we give this information
to games and applications
all in less than
five milliseconds,
achieving an overall
display latency
of around 20 milliseconds.
At the same time, the
system is building,
of course, a 3D
model of the scene,
recognizing features
it's seen before so
that it can correct any drift
that may occur over time.
You may have heard this
referred to as SLAM,
or Simultaneous
Localization and Mapping.
So that's a high-level
review of what WorldSense is.
It eliminates one of
the major differences
between desktop and
mobile VR today.
Now, in smartphone
AR, AR applications
require sensing even
more of the environment
to be able to place digital
objects in front of us
accurately enough to seem as
though they physically exist.
And today, Tango phones
use additional sensors
to enable a richer set of
augmented reality experiences
than is possible with
a standard phone.
We have a dedicated
depth sensor that
allows games to understand the
difference between the floor,
the table, and the
walls, and even
lets the characters hide
behind things like couches.
We have a wide-angle
camera for tracking
that gives us the best view
of the features in the room,
allowing very robust positional
tracking in the phone.
And this also
improves our ability
to quickly re-localize
so we can recognize where
we are in the room, letting
you see AR content that
was set there before or
even left by other people.
So to give you an example
of the kind of experiences
that you can do with all
this technology put together,
I wanted to share
with you this project
that we've been doing with
the Singapore Art and Science
Museum.
Do we have audio for the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: Most people
living in cities
have never been to a rainforest.
So we decided to bring
a rainforest to a city
and make it accessible
for everyone.
For that, we needed a
new mobile technology.
We were able to map 10,000
square feet of a museum space
into a rainforest.
Visitors experienced
what it's like to walk
through a rainforest, learned
about endangered animals
threatened by
deforestation and were
tasked to plant a virtual tree.
SPEAKER 2: We were able
to launch this experience
on the first Tango-enabled
device, the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro,
and bring AR at scale to
everyone, making "Into The
Wild" the largest AR
experience in the world.
JOHNNY LEE: So sorry
about missing the--
oh, yeah, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So the exhibit actually
allows thousands of visitors
to come and experience
a digital rainforest.
And when they pledge a donation
to the World Wildlife Fund,
they actually are
allowed to plant a tree,
and other visitors can see
that tree grow in the museum.
And the rainforest starts
to expand over time
as visitors see the exhibit.
We're still in the
early days of seeing
how these experiences
will evolve,
so this is just a glimpse
into what's possible today.
The first phone featuring
Tango-enabled capabilities
was the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro,
which hit shelves last fall.
Our second phone is the
ZenFone AR from ASUS.
And I'm really glad to
announce that customers
will be able to
experience the ZenFone
in Verizon stores
across the United States
later this summer.
And over the next
year, you'll see
us bring Tango functionality
to many, many more phones.
And we really just believe
this is the beginning.
We've seen a variety
of great applications
begin to appear
that take advantage
of these new capabilities.
For example, we
have tools that can
help you measure the
size of the table in case
you're interested in buying
one for your dining room.
Or you can do things
like walk around
your house with the tracking
sensors and the depth sensor
to generate a heat map of
the Wi-Fi signal strength
within your apartment
or in the building.
And this actually lets
you help find dead spots,
or where you might
want to put the router,
or even buy a repeater.
You can even use estimate
the square footage
of your apartment,
which might actually
come in handy if you're thinking
about moving into a new place
or even renegotiating your rent.
There's games like
"World" by Phenomena
which allow you to carry
a toy box in your pocket.
And yesterday, you heard about
the Visual Positioning Service
from Clay, which opens
up many new experiences
around indoor location
and navigation.
With the permission
of each venue,
we use the wide-angle
camera in the Tango phone
to give us a broad view
of the environment.
And this allows us to generate
large-scale descriptions
of the space.
And this enables
centimeter-scale accurate
positioning within the building.
It's a lot like GPS.
But rather than
talking to satellites
1,000 miles above
the Earth, it's
using features that are
just a few feet away
to calculate its position.
This is what we actually
use in the Art and Science
Museum that allows us to anchor
trees in the environment.
In stores like
Lowe's, it can get
you walking directions
directly to an item sitting
on the shelf.
We're still in the
early days of what
we feel like will be possible
with these technologies,
and it lets us see
things in new ways
that we couldn't see before.
So it helps us learn more
about the environment.
It helps us find our way through
spaces and share knowledge
with other people in a
physical and visual medium.
But one of the
things it helps us do
is learn better, especially when
we are able to make connections
with those who are
seeing the same thing
at the same time from their
own unique perspective.
And in this way, the
power of AR isn't
in just adding digital objects
to the camera view in front
of us, but in adding shared
meaning to the interaction
between people.
So to tell you more about
how shared AR experiences can
help in a classroom, let
me hand off to Jen Holland.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER HOLLAND: Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Johnny.
I'm Jennifer Holland, and I'm
the education program manager
on Daydream.
Johnny shared some updates
about the applications of Tango,
as well as areas
where we think AR can
have a big immediate impact.
Education is just
one of those areas.
And my team took advantage
of Tango's sensor stack
and built a tool for
schools so that teachers
could create
immersive experiences
with their students.
And that's the same
technology that's actually
available to all of you.
Two years ago, we
launched Expeditions VR.
And we've built
more than 600 tours,
and we've heard from
thousands of kids
from around the world
who have sent us
personal letters sharing how
Expeditions has inspired them.
We've learned a great
deal from talking
to the over 2 million
teachers and students
who have actually used it.
And one of the most important
things that my team learned
was that you really need to
embrace the key functions
of a classroom.
That is, students
engaging, interacting,
and learning with each other,
as well as their teacher.
Tango's camera and
sensor are what
makes this interaction
possible in real time.
And no, I promise you
those kids are not
taking selfies in their class.
Teachers are able to accurately
map the physical classroom
and place 3D objects, like
one of Michelangelo's statues,
right on the student's desks
so that all students can
look at the statue
together in real time.
Students can move the
Tango-enabled phone
to get up close
to see the detail
or take a step back to
get a sense of the scale
and be able to point out new
discoveries on the statue
together.
And that's powerful because
it's not each individual student
looking at their own object,
like a whirling category 5
hurricane.
It's as if you actually
brought the hurricane
into the classroom.
Students can view any object,
from a strand of DNA to one
of Saturn's rings, together.
And those objects
don't disappear
when the students look away.
And a teacher is
able to point out
specific things on the
object to suit the lesson.
Just think how cool it
would be for a teacher
to transform their
entire classroom
into a world-class art
museum and display the works
of van Gogh, Monet, or
even the "Mona Lisa" right
on the same classroom walls.
As an education
product team, we're
committed to leveraging
the same Tango
technology available to you
and tweaking it slightly
to give teachers
a tool to create
immersive experiences each and
every day in their classroom.
And just like we did
with Expeditions VR,
we're going to be bringing this
tool to schools through the AR
Expeditions Pioneer Program.
And schools can sign up if
they're interested for a visit.
And if you're a developer
really excited about building
AR lessons with us, let us
know by expressing interest
on our partner page.
That's Expeditions AR.
That is just one thing
that you can do with Tango.
And we're really excited to see
what all of you come up with.
Now, let's switch gears
and talk about another part
of the Immersive
Computing Spectrum.
Let me welcome Mike to tell
you the latest about Daydream,
our platform for
high-performance mobile VR.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE JAZAYERI: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Mike Jazayeri, and I'm the
director of product management
for Daydream.
Daydream serves as the
foundation of our investments
in immersive computing.
We began working on
Daydream in 2015,
with the initial
goal of bringing
high-performance
smartphone VR to Android.
Today, I'm excited to tell you
about what's next for Daydream.
But first, a quick refresher
on how we got here.
So the first version of
Daydream launched in November
and was built on
three core elements--
the Daydream-ready specs for
phones, a high-performance VR
mode in Android N, and
of course, the Daydream
experience, including
Play Store in VR.
We promised to create
a large ecosystem
of Daydream-ready devices.
And I'm very proud to say
that in just six months,
there are eight Daydream-ready
devices on market.
And as Clay announced yesterday,
Samsung's flagship S8 and S8
Plus will soon be
Daydream-ready,
with an update
coming this summer.
They're fantastic
phones, and you're
going to love the Daydream
experience on them.
But that's not all.
LG's next flagship
phone, launching
in the second half of this year,
will also be Daydream-ready.
In addition to
these new partners,
existing partners,
including Motorola and ASUS,
will have more
Daydream-ready phones.
So when you put
all that together,
there will be tens of millions
of Daydream-ready phones
in consumers' hands by
the end of the year.
I think that's a
really big deal.
And I want to thank our
partners, who've been
working really hard on that.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's the start.
Now let's talk about
what's coming next.
This year at Google I/O, we're
announcing two major updates
to Daydream.
The first is support
for a brand new category
of standalone headsets.
And second is a major update to
the Daydream software platform.
We're going to call this 2.0
release Daydream Euphrates.
Let's talk about both, and
let's start with headsets.
So as Clay announced yesterday,
the standalone headset
takes everything that we
love about smartphone VR
and makes it even better.
All you need for
VR-- the software,
the hardware-- is in
one integrated device.
It's much more immersive
because of WorldSense.
And you can get into
VR in just seconds.
You just put the headset
on, you're ready to go.
No extra wires, PCs,
or setup required.
Now, for these
standalone headsets,
we wanted to create a
large ecosystem of devices
and of content, and doing
so requires great hardware.
So we've partnered
deeply with Qualcomm
to create a reference
standalone headset.
This is featuring this powerful
Snapdragon 835 chipset,
custom-designed
tracking cameras,
and high-performance sensors.
Now, those tracking
cameras are particularly
important because they enable
a much more immersive VR
experience with WorldSense,
which Johnny just talked about.
But a reference headset
isn't all that we're doing.
We're also partnering with
two leading device makers
to actually bring these
headsets to market starting
at the end of the year.
HTC really needs no
introduction in the world of VR.
They're already a leader in this
space with the Vive headset.
They're going to
bring their expertise
in headset design, optics, and
building high-performance VR
systems to Daydream.
Our other partner is Lenovo.
And they've been a
longtime partner of ours.
And we worked together
to bring this first Tango
phone to market.
So they're already
a pioneer in AR,
and they're going to bring
that same pioneering spirit
to Daydream.
So that's standalone headsets.
But powerful hardware also
requires powerful software.
And that's where the next
version of Daydream--
Daydream Euphrates-- comes in.
We focused on three
things for this release.
First is all the
software support
you need for
standalone headsets.
Second is making VR content
front and center, the content
that you've built. And third
is making it easy for users
to share that VR content
with friends and family,
whether they're
sitting right next
to them or around the world.
So let's talk about each one.
Daydream Euphrates
takes advantage
of even deeper support for
VR that's in Android O--
in particular, the
capabilities needed
to support standalone headsets.
So if you think
about it, Android
has been designed
for devices that
primarily run touchscreens.
But a standalone headset, by
definition, has no touchscreen.
So we've had to build a
new VR window manager deep
into Android so that
we have an operating
system where all the system
UI will be accessible in VR.
Also with Daydream
Euphrates, we're
updating the Daydream home
experience for both smartphones
and standalone headsets.
First, we're going to
make it easy to discover
the best content in VR.
You'll see a curated list of
continuously updated stream
of content with
thematic collections,
mixing together thousands of
videos, experiences, games,
and apps.
Now, once you're in
the VR experience,
we don't want to break
that sense of immersion.
So Daydream Euphrates
also has a new dashboard
that embraces the
immersive nature of VR
and appears right
on top of any app.
It's superfast to load
and lets you stay in VR.
You won't have to
leave the experience
to check a notification,
change settings, or even
to switch apps.
So now that we've made
it easy to stay in VR,
we want to help you share that
experience with others, even
if they're not
wearing a VR headset.
So today, I'm excited to
announce Cast support is
coming to Daydream.
With this feature--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It's one of our
top-requested features.
So with this feature, you'll be
able to pull up the dashboard
and simply select a
casting destination.
As you go from app to app,
your Cast station stays.
Now, casting, what I
love about it is it
changes the VR experience
from an individual experience
to a shared experience
and really brings
your friends and family
into the fun with you.
Now, casting is good for people
who are physically near you.
But what about everyone else?
To help you share your
favorite moments in VR,
we're also adding the
ability to capture
a screenshot or a short video
of your Daydream experience
and share it on your favorite
social media or messaging app.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
OK.
So that's a quick look at what's
coming with Daydream Euphrates.
In addition to this, there's
many, many other features,
including many for developers.
And you can learn more about
that in our other sessions
or obviously on our
developer website.
To sum it all up, we've
got tens of millions
of Daydream-ready phones
by the end of the year,
a new class of
standalone VR headsets,
and a brand new update
to the Daydream software
we call Euphrates that's
coming later this year
for both smartphone VR and
for standalone headsets.
So finally, I spoke
a little bit ago
about making it easier to share
your VR experience with others.
We think this is really critical
for users to keep them engaged
and also where, perhaps, where
some of the most innovative
experiences will come.
So let me welcome Erin
from the YouTube VR team
who's going to
tell you about some
of the things YouTube VR
is doing to make shared
experiences a reality.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN TEAGUE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Erin.
I'm a product manager from
the VR team at YouTube.
We made an early bet on
360-degree and 3D video
and thought a lot about
how to build the YouTube VR
app from the ground
up for Daydream.
It does everything you
love about YouTube,
but in a way that feels
natural in a virtual world.
Since we launched, people's
responses have blown us away.
Every time I pop in, there's
something new to explore,
from sports highlights
to historic landmarks,
deep sea dives to
learning about dinosaurs.
No matter what you're
passionate about,
YouTube and VR can
take you there,
thanks to the huge library
of hundreds of thousands
of immersive videos.
So there are all
these amazing places
you can go, see,
and learn about.
You probably want to share these
experiences with other people.
It's just better that way.
From co-watching parties
to creators engaging
with their fans, YouTube already
has an incredible community
that's built around its content.
And we want to bring that to VR.
So here's a sneak
peek into something
that we're working on.
Later this year,
we'll be rolling out
an update that lets
you co-watch YouTube
videos with other people,
talk about them live,
and share the experience all
in the same virtual room.
Everyone will be
able to customize
the way that they look in VR.
And with just a
click, you can sync in
to watch what others
are watching, too.
For example, anyone can connect
with other Gorillaz fans
to watch their latest music
video in a virtual front row.
For me, VR video goes well
beyond games, entertainment,
and music.
So many creators,
like this one, use
VR to inspire empathy
and compassion.
In fact, there is
no other technology
that lets you walk in
someone else's shoes,
experience things that
you can't in real life,
and gain a new perspective
on important topics.
With this update to YouTube
VR and the addition of casting
and capture to Daydream,
which Mike announced,
there will soon be more ways
for you to enjoy VR together.
Now let me pass
this off to Andrey,
who's going to talk to you a
bit about tools for VR and AR
developers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREY DORONICHEV:
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Andrey.
I lead apps and developer
tools at Daydream.
Hey, so much exciting progress
on AR and VR platform side.
But of course, platforms are
defined by the best experiences
available in them--
experiences built by
developers like you.
To build great stuff,
you need great tools.
So today, I want to tell
you about three new tools
we developed to help
you iterate faster,
push the limits of
mobile graphics,
and bring your immersive
experiences to the whole world.
First of all, let's talk
about iteration time.
It's early days of
immersive computing,
so it's all about experimenting.
You need to be able to
try many new ideas as
quickly as possible.
And to evaluate VR
content, you really
need to experience it firsthand
in the target hardware.
But we know from many
mobile developers,
it might take minutes from when
you make a change in the editor
to when you see the
result on device.
We timed it.
It takes three minutes,
sometimes, but maybe five
or seven for a larger project.
I can hit Build, go
toast myself a bagel,
and come back before
it's done deploying.
So we knew we had to take
the iteration time down
from minutes to seconds.
And that is why we
built Instant Preview.
This is a tool that lets you
make changes in your desktop
and instantly see them
in your VR device.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Instant Preview is
deeply integrated
in both the editor
and the mobile device.
We send the sensor data from
the headset and the controller
to the PC, which emulates
and renders the scene.
And the result is sent back to
the device as a stereo video
stream.
And the cool thing is that
we can do it with low latency
so that you can comfortably
use it in VR while tweaking
interactions in real time.
The result is a continuous,
uninterrupted development flow.
Instant Preview
is launching today
for both Unity and Unreal.
You can download it right now.
Check it out.
[APPLAUSE]
Now let's talk about graphics.
VR makes you feel like
you're somewhere else.
So the visual fidelity of
the virtual environment
matters a lot.
And of course, with six
degree of freedom devices,
you just can't get away
by wrapping a 360 panorama
as a background.
You have to render
a full 3D scene.
However, what you can render in
real time depends on the amount
of power you have available.
There's a huge gap between what
you can do on a 4-watt mobile
device, a 400-watt PC, or,
say, a 4,000-node render farm.
But what if we could
bridge this gap?
What if we could achieve
desktop-level graphics
on a mobile VR headset,
like our standalone?
We can't change the laws
of physics, of course,
but we can be very clever.
I want to introduce a
new tool we call Seurat,
after the great French painter.
With this tool, you can
take a high-fidelity scene,
like one from a PC game, and run
it in mobile VR in real time.
How does this work?
As a developer,
you define a volume
within which you want
the user to move around
and view your scene.
You also define
target parameters,
like number of
polygons and overdraw.
And then you let the
tool do its magic.
It takes dozens of images
from different parts
of this defined volume, and
then it automatically generates
an entirely new 3D scene that
looks identical to the original
but is dramatically simplified.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
And you still can have dynamic
interactive elements in it.
So yeah, it's pretty cool.
But wait a minute.
If we can do
something like this,
why would you stop at
desktop-level graphics?
What if you take a scene so
complex it can't possibly
run in real time, even
on the most powerful PC,
like something from a movie?
Let me show you a project
we worked on with ILM X
Lab, the branch
of Lucasfilm that
is focused on pioneering
next-generation immersive
experiences.
One of their goals is to bring
you inside of "Star Wars."
Let's see what they've been
able to do with Seurat.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VICKI DOBBS BECK:
ILM X Lab's mission
is really to create
immersive, premium,
story-based entertainment
experiences.
And our goal is
for people to step
inside the worlds of our
stories, and in this case,
into the world of "Star Wars."
JOHN KNOLL: When there are
events, locations, characters,
something that has
to be fabricated,
they turn to visual effects
to create that imagery.
JOHN GAETA: The depth of
the world that we would
like to step into is as
thoughtful and creative
and exacting as anything
we might put in our films.
MICHAEL KOPERWAS: This
new technology from Google
is enabling us to do
something we've been
trying to find for a while.
We take high-quality
cinematic renders
and we can turn
them into something
that's real time consumable.
LEWEY GESELOWITZ: When X Lab
was approached by Google,
they said that they could
take our ILM renders
and make them run in
real time on a VR phone.
Turns out it's true.
JOHN KNOLL: You can have
very dense, complex scenes
with very sophisticated shading
that traditionally can't
run in real time on an engine.
LEWEY GESELOWITZ: When
I see people in our demo
looking at the floor, and
going on their hands and knees,
down to inspect the curvature
of every little bend and twist,
I really think we're
on to something.
JOHN GAETA: That
potentially opens the door
to cinematic realism in VR.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANDREY DORONICHEV:
So ILM X Lab brought
the cinema-quality
world of "Rogue 1"
onto our mobile VR headset.
This scene is around 50 million
triangles and three gigabytes
of textures.
Normally, each frame
here takes an hour
to render offline on a
high-performance machine.
However, after
processing with Seurat,
it now takes 13 milliseconds
per frame on a mobile GPU.
[APPLAUSE]
We reduced the texture
size by a factor of 300
and the number of polygons
by a factor of 1,000.
Now it's comfortably running in
real time on our standalone VR
headset with six
degrees of freedom.
And it looks as good
as the original.
How cool is that?
Well, with this technology,
you, as a developer,
will be able to build
visually stunning experiences
while still targeting
mobile VR hardware.
Seurat already supports
Unity and Real and Maya,
and we are currently
experimenting
with a smaller set of partners.
We'll start rolling out the tool
more broadly later this year.
So please stay tuned.
All right.
Now let's talk about the
world's largest developer
ecosystem, the web.
Three years ago, we
coauthored Web VR Spec.
It allowed developers to build
immersive 3D applications
with JavaScript and Web GL
and run them in the browser.
This way, you're leveraging
the strength of the web itself.
Your code is
standards-based, it adapts
to different kinds
of devices, and it's
easy to distribute
it with a link.
Now, imagine you're a
user in a VR headset.
Where do you go to discover
a web VR experience?
How do you surf the web in VR?
Well, I'm excited to announce
we're bringing the full Chrome
browser in VR.
Let me show you a preview.
You'll be able to use Daydream
controller to navigate
any regular web page
and follow links.
And for web VR
experiences, you just
get transported into
fully-immersive worlds.
And of course, you'll
be able to watch any web
video in a theater-like
environment
with a large screen.
What I love about
Chrome in VR is
that it's the same app I'm
using for browsing in 2D, which
means all of my
bookmarks, history,
and tabs are already there.
I don't have to re-log into
my favorite websites in VR.
Things just work.
Browsing in VR feels
great, and it's
coming to Chrome for
Android later this year.
But the web is not only
for virtual reality.
We actually see big
potential in the context
of augmented reality, too.
You see, web connects
the world's information,
and AR connects information
with the physical world.
So together, they can be applied
for solving real life problems.
I want to show you what
AR features in the browser
could look like.
Let's say you're searching
for a new coffee table.
You're probably
browsing online stores,
and you're looking at some
pictures on your phone.
But you don't really want
pictures on the phone.
You want the furniture
in your room.
This is one example where
connecting the physical world
and information
would be very handy.
With AR-enabled browser,
your favorite web site
could ask you to mark the
physical space you have
available, and
then it would only
show you the items
that fit in this area.
And of course, you'll be
able to preview search
results in the context of your
actual room from any angle.
And you know what's cool?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You know what's cool?
You didn't have to install
a new app just for that.
Everything you've seen here is
built with JavaScript and Web
GL, and it's running in
our experimental browser.
So with the web, we
will enable developers
to easily integrate AR features
into your existing websites.
Just like we did
with web VR, we're
starting by releasing
an experimental build
of Chromium, which
exposes AR features
like positional and depth data.
It's available today.
You can download it from GitHub.
And we're excited to see what
the community does with it.
Our goal is to make web VR and
web AR first-class citizens
in all browsers.
And that is it for
Developer Tools.
Thanks so much for spending
some of your morning with us.
We'll look forward to
partnering with you,
making sure you have both
the platforms and the tools
to bring your next
great idea to life.
Make sure you check
out our other talks,
and come over to the Tango
booth to check out the demo.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]